[Musique]
on a échangé c'est vrai que le président
le président aime le foot monsieur
sarkozy aussi il vient souvent au parc
des princes donc on a beaucoup échangé
sur cette éventualité de de continuer à
paris ou de partir à madrid mais ils
m'ont et m'ont fortement conseillé de de
continuer dans mon pays de continuer
encore un peu à écrire l'histoire du
paris saint germain mais avant tout
c'était quand même ma décision et je les
prises personnellement et donc je suis
content de ce choix là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
hu
[Musique]
merci d'insérer une autre pièce
merci dents serrées encore une pièce
mon pour boire
mon pourboire
merci beaucoup bonne journée